Heute Abend sind sie bei uns bei Verstehen Sie Spaß?
mit einer Fernseh-Weltpremiere.
Hier sind die unglaublichen Ehrlich Brothers!
(Applaus)
Hi Chris!
- Grüß dich!
(Applaus)
Wow!
Was habt ihr heute Abend bei uns vor?
Erst mal freuen wir uns megamäßig,
wieder hier zu sein!
Aber wir sind auch echt nervös,
weil zum ersten mal im Fernsehen
werden wir einen Entfesselungs-Stunt probieren,
der wirklich gefährlich ist.
Es geht um Fesseln, es geht um
Schlösser und es ist live
das heißt es kann auch wirklich was schief gehen.
Wir haben viel geprobt
vor allen Dingen Andreas.
- Wo ist dein Bruder?
Bruder, wie sieht's aus, was erwartet die Zuschauer?
Genau, ich bin hier auf dem Entfesselungstisch
denn ich werde jetzt den Versuch unternehmen,
mich mit einer weltweit einzigartigen Technik
zu entfesseln.
Wichtig ist, dass alles untersucht wird
das alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Komm mal kurz mit.
Nee, das kann ich nicht machen weil ich bin
hier wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu parteiisch.
Wir haben einen neutralen Schweizer da.
Bobo, würdest du mitkommen zu den Ehrlich Brothers?
(Applaus)
Ihr seid doch so neutral?
Hi!
- Hi!
Komm mal mit!
Wichtig bei einem Entfesselungs-Stunt ist die Gefahr,
am Ende dieses Stunts
muss es eine Todesgefahr geben,
damit das Ganze spannend ist.
Und bei diesem Stunt ist es
ein zwei Meter großes Sägeblatt
was über meinem Bruder thront
und Schritt für Schritt
innerhalb von 15 Sekunden auf
ihn herabsinken wird.
Mein Bruder wird gefesselt - Jungs fesselt
ihn!
Und deine Aufgabe ist es ist einfach mal zu checken.
Nimm mal ein paar Ketten, untersuch mal.
Nicht, dass sie irgendwie aus Plastik sind oder so.
- Sieht gut aus.
- Alles massiv?
- Ja!
Hier das Schloss,
schauen wir mal, ob das massiv ist.
Schließ das mal ruhig ab.
Richtig solide, zieh mal richtig dran!
- Sehr solide!
- Schweizer Qualität
- Meinst du? (lacht)
- Alles klar?
- Alles klar!
- Okay, dann vielen Dank!
- Toi toi toi!
- Danke
(Applaus)
Es gibt insgesamt 15 Schlösser
und diesen einen Schlüssel.
Was ist das besondere an diesem Stunt?
Der Schlüssel kommt nicht einfach in die Hand
sondern dieser Schlüssel ist
am Anfang dieses Stunts
im Mund von Andreas.
Wenn du schaffst, alle
Schlösser zu öffnen
dann hast du den Weltrekord!
Wenn du Schluckauf bekommst
habe ich zwei Halbbrüder.
Darum kümmert er sich
höchstpersönlich.
(Sägeblatt rotiert)
Ok!
Lets Go!
Yes!
Hey!
Der Schlüssel!
Stoppt die Säge!
Ehm... das sah bei der Probe anders aus...
Ja, ehm, liebe Kinder,
wie soll ich das erklären...
Eine optische Illusion!
In Wahrheit liegt sein Körper
unter diesem Sägeblatt drunter.
Hier ist ein geheimes Fach...
(Publikum lacht)
Da hilft nur noch Ablenkung!
Bruder, das war es nicht wert!
Ah!
Aaaah!
War doch nur Spaß!
(Applaus)
Wie soll ich sagen?
Das sieht ja nur so aus als wären die Beine ab.
In Wirklichkeit sind die Beine...
Warum ist das nass?
Pf... Angstschweiß?
Ich hab den Schlüssel verloren,
der muss ja irgendwo liegen.
Gib mir den mal.
Hier!
Sag mal, wie geht's denn meinen Beinen?
"Gehen" ist übertrieben.
Was ist mit meinen Beinen, Bruder?
Puls ist normal!
Gib mir mal die Beine rüber!
Mir hat mal ein Chirurg gesagt,
wenn man unter ner Minute bleibt
mit dem Drannähen, dann...
(Publikum lacht)
Bruder?
Beeil dich mal ein bisschen!
Los!
Mit dem linken Bein fangen wir an.
Linkes Bein zuerst!
Moment mal (lacht)
Du ohne Beine...
...bist voll klein!
Du bist ja quasi mein kleiner Bruder! (lacht)
(Musik)
Und ich der große Bruder!
Geil! So bleibts!
Hammer!
- Ehm, Moment Mal!
Das kannst du nicht machen!
Das sind meine Beine!
Bruder!
(Musik)
(Publikum klatscht)
Hey!
Hierhin!
Bei Fuß!
Ach, mein Fuß ist ja woanders...
- Ich wollte doch immer schon mal
in so einem Musikvideo mittanzen!
Jetzt ist die Chance da!
- Nicht mit meinen Beinen!
Hammer!
Das ist geil, oder? (lacht)
(Musik)
Bruder, du hast deinen Applaus gehabt
jetzt gib mir meine Beine!
Ja Moment!
Wie heißt das Zauberwort?
Bitte!
Hol sie dir doch!
Haha!
Manuel, komm mal her bitte.
Hol du mir mal bitte meine Beine!
Ich kann ja nicht!
Ah, du willst die Beine?
Guck mal, Kniebeugen gehen voll leicht!
Ja du, such dir eins aus! (lacht)
Nene, nicht das, das ist mein eigenes!
Guck mal hier, ich kann mich auch verwirren...
Kennst du Shakespear?
Sein oder nicht sein Bein?
Welches Schweindel hättens denn jetzt gerne?
Aua, nein nein nicht das da, aua!!
Beinhart geht das ab hier...
Manuel, das ist ein Bein...
Ich habe aber zwei Beine...
Bruder!
Ein bisschen Finderlohn muss sein!
Ich kann ja auch hier noch weiter tanzen...
Das ist geil, oder?
Okay, du bekommst sie zurück!
Aber das tut jetzt ein bisschen weh okay?
Aua! Ich hab immer noch Gefühle
in den Beinen!
- Ja, sorry!
So, das Bein muss runter.
Und du leg dich jetzt mal auf den Rücken.
Jetzt tut es ein bisschen weh, okay?
Boah, Hammer!?
Funktioniert!
Yey!
(Musik und Applaus)